[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID PESSIS: Thank you,
everybody, for coming.
Super excited about
this discussion.
Excited to present with
Daniel and Bhaskara from CBS.
Very cool story how they
migrated off of Teradata
into BigQuery and GCP.
Before we get into
that awesome story,
Bhaskara has given me
three minutes of permission
to talk about some of the cool
things coming out of BigQuery.
So does everybody
know what BigQuery is?
Can I see a show of hands?
I can kind of see.
I'm not going to
really go into this.
OK.
The only thing I like to call
out is that it's serverless.
It's a fully managed and
serverless environment
to do your big data analysis.
And again, one of
the cool things
that I love about
BigQuery is we want
to take care of all that
operational annoying stuff,
and so that you guys can
focus on running your queries
and running your
analysis, and that's
what that serverless thing
enables you guys to do.
So we can do that heavy
lifting, so you guys
can do all the fun stuff and
get insights out of your data.
So BigQuery's been
around for a while.
And it's a very powerful tool.
It's a very powerful platform.
And what we've been
weak in in the past
is helping our customers
migrate into BigQuery.
And so we like to call
these the onramps.
So we have very weak
onramps until now.
And just recently,
if you guys have
been following some
of the announcements,
we just launched a data
warehouse migration service.
And so that includes three
different services, one,
Teradata migration,
which is awesome.
We'll talk about
that a little bit.
For the next, CBS,
hopefully it makes
it a little easier
and a little faster
for them to migrate
into BigQuery.
So that's in beta.
If you go to the console and
you click on the Data Transfer
Service, you can actually
migrate schema and data pretty
seamlessly into BigQuery.
We also launched a
Redshift migration service,
which is an alpha.
So if you guys want to
reach out to your customer
service or your partner
or your account executive,
we can whitelist you for that.
And then S3.
So if you have data
in AWS, you can put it
in Parquet files or
Avro files into S3,
and we can automatically
load those into BigQuery.
So super excited
about this service.
And again, hopefully, if Daniel
and Bhaskara did this again,
it would be a little
bit easier for them.
So with that, I'm supposed
to get off the stage now.
But really excited
introduce you to Bhaskara.
And take it away.
BHASKARA PETA: Hello, everyone.
From CBS Interactive,
we'll have Dan
and I will come into the
stage in a few minutes.
But I'll first to go over
some of the high-level details
of the migration.
And these are the topics that
we are going to cover today.
Trust me, this is
not a sales pitch.
I just want to give
you a high-level idea
of CBS Interactive, what we do.
To give you some sense of
scale and background on CBSI,
we are the largest
premium content company,
and ranked at number
7 per Comscore report.
After YouTube, we are
Google's largest ad partner.
And within the
verticals we serve,
our brands are leaders and
number one in all categories
outside of sports, where
we trail only behind ESPN.
And CBSI is well-positioned to
be the network of the future.
And we have reach across TV,
entertainment, news, sports,
and more and more local
news, live streaming.
Huge growth for us in connected
TV space and OTT platforms.
Before going into the
details of today's topic,
I have a quick question
for the audience.
How many of you are
actually planning
to migrate to the cloud?
I don't know if I
can see everyone,
but I could see some hands
are rising, so it's good.
So first, I'll show you
the platform that we
have before the migration.
And at a high level, this is
our infrastructure footprint.
And if you look at it, we
have 27-node Teradata cluster
with 120-terabyte disk
space and 22 Hadoop
nodes of 1-petabyte disk space.
And also, we have a
[? 60P ?] Informatica server,
we have automation
engine, Tableau,
which is our BI reporting
and visualization tool.
And we have data products
wherein we create custom
dashboards which cannot
be done through Tableau.
So this is our footprint
at a high level.
And if you look at the
data flow, the data
we acquire through internal
and external APIs, and also
internal databases, we acquire
into HDR files and also NFS
and process through
Hive and Teradata.
And we also copy most recent
data from Hive to Teradata
almost daily basis.
This is mainly because of the
database constraints we have--
size constraints on Teradata.
And also, if you look at
Tableau and other data product
applications, we have the
choice of querying either Hive
or Teradata, so there is a
flexibility our analysts have.
And if you look at some of the
challenges that we are having,
scale.
If you are familiar with
database appliances,
it is not easy to increase
the size without going
through a lot of effort.
It requires a lot of money,
resources, and it's not easy.
And same thing with Hadoop.
We have to plan a lot.
And if you look at
SLAs, in the past,
we had frequent delays
in SLAs and sometimes, we
were delayed by
four to six hours.
And for us, data is
critical because ours
is a media company, and we
are not short of major events.
We have major events throughout
the year starting in January
all the way to December.
And we start with the CES, and
then March Madness, Super Bowl,
a lot of news events and
a lot of other all access
original launches, and
a lot of other events.
So there are a lot of
problems with the SLAs,
so that is one of the challenge.
And SQL, I'm sure
some of you also
might have in your companies.
We have a few users
who could bring down
the database to its knees.
And of course, it
is not by intention.
Everybody writes inefficient
sequence at times,
even I do too.
So whenever those
inefficient sequences
are going into Teradata, the
performance is going down.
And then we do the
backups almost every week.
And whenever the
backups are happening,
the performance is degraded.
And every Monday, we
always constantly have
to monitor how the
reports are coming along
because we have seen most
of the delays on Mondays.
And also the concurrent users.
If the number of users are
increased on the system,
it is typical with some of
these [INAUDIBLE] databases
that the database
performance will go down.
So these are some of the
challenges that we are having.
And right around
that time, there
was a company-wide
cloud-first initiative
which helped us
to actually start
thinking about cloud migration.
And also, CBSI and
Google are good partners.
We have been using Google's
products-- for example,
we have been using DFP,
which is DART For Publishers,
and also G Suite.
So it was a natural
evolution for us
and it was the right fit to
start looking at Google Cloud,
and that is how we
started our migration.
So let us see how we
actually did the migration.
We considered a few options
before going into BigQuery.
So option number one is
migrate only data to BigQuery.
And option number two,
migrate entire platform,
meaning infrastructure,
processes, data--
everything to cloud.
However, this option
number two sounds
good, but with the given
time and resources,
we thought that it is
not possible to do it.
So we looked at a middle ground,
which is option number three.
So now let us look at
what that option three is
and what are some of
details of option three.
So migrate data
to cloud, meaning
wherever the data
is processed, we
have to have the
data in the cloud.
That way, all the
users will have access
to one single database
for their analysis.
And second, Big Data.
So we thought that processing
the Big Data in the cloud
would help us a
lot because that is
where we have most
of the challenges,
and we tackled that first.
And when I say Big Data,
mainly around click
stream data, which is the web
traffic and ad impression data.
And also, there were no
technical constraints for us
not to migrate the
processes into the cloud,
so it made it easy for
making the decision.
While we did that, we also
changed the data structures
for these big data
sets, and that helped
us a lot with performance.
And of course, we did
this in consultation
with a task force
which was formed
by inviting some of
the key stakeholders
from our businesses, and
that worked out pretty good.
And I'll give you some
more details later on.
And also, if you look at
the dimension processing,
it is not--
while BigQuery is very good
and high-performance database,
we cannot do traditional--
the DMLs like we do with
traditional databases.
Whereas Informatica
process that we
had had a lot of
in-service updates,
deletes on a daily basis.
We couldn't do that, so
we looked at Informatica
replacement at that time.
However, we couldn't
find a good replacement.
And also, with the given
time and resources,
we decided, OK, we are going
to keep Informatica for now
on-premise.
However, copy all the
process data to the cloud
because ultimately,
the goal is to have
all the data in the cloud.
We also decided to keep all
the Hadoop jobs on-premise.
However, we made a simple change
by writing the output files
not only to Hadoop,
but also to GCS.
And this gave us a leverage to
reduce the time of migration.
Also, at the time of
decommissioning Hadoop,
it made it easy for us.
Data product applications.
We decided to migrate the
application code first,
while keeping the
Teradata on-premise.
Because while the
code is in the cloud,
the applications were talking
to the database on the premise.
So we did that because
we wanted to make
simultaneous progress
with multiple,
I would say, lanes, projects.
So those are the
[INAUDIBLE] we took.
And likewise, the BI
reporting servers,
we kept them on-premise.
This is also purely
because of time.
Otherwise, there is
no technical reason.
So that also we kept on-premise.
And the next one, I'll show
you the timeline and how
all this migration took place.
So we start in March 2017.
That's when we started planning
and started looking at all
the new tools and technologies
because we are going into a new
platform-- brand new platform--
and we need to evaluate
what is out there
and what we need to do
with all the new tools.
So it took us about six
months, and by August 2017,
we are actually ready to
start migrating or start
working on the actual code.
So from August
through January, we
have migrated the code that is
required for the first business
unit.
So by January 2018, our
first BU is ready to go live.
And as you can
see at the bottom,
it took us about 11 months
for the first site to go live,
which is amazing.
And then, by May, we are
live with all the business
units in BigQuery.
All of this took 15 months.
And then, if you
look at July 2018,
that is when we shut
down the Teradata.
So we kept running the
Teradata between May and July
for about two months
just as a fallback.
In case, if anybody has
any doubt on anything,
they can always go back.
But in July, we started
shutting down the Teradata.
And between July and December,
we converted Hadoop jobs.
And then, by December, we
were able to shut down Hadoop.
So all this has
happened over 22 months.
And as you can see, we have
supported three different data
platforms over an
extended period
of time, which is not easy.
And also, we had to migrate
this data over many, many brands
where the priorities are
different for each business
unit.
And also, we did
all this with a team
of eight dedicated
engineers with some help
from other engineers
across the company.
And it was a great
team effort and we
have excellent stakeholders
who have helped us
with a lot of testing
early on, and overall it
was a great team effort.
So now, I'm going
to hand off to Dan,
who will talk to you about
some of the technical details
of the migration.
Dan?
DANIEL LESCOHIER: OK, so
I'll cover the Google Cloud
architecture that replaced
the on-prem systems that we're
retiring, the migration
strategies for our big data
acquisition jobs, our ETL
jobs, and our historical data,
and the technical
challenges that we
encountered during the project.
So the scope of the project was
to retire Hadoop and Teradata
and move our data
products to the cloud.
So Hadoop and Teradata
are going to be gone, so
what do we replace them with?
So for the big data
acquisition scripts,
they used to write to the
Hadoop Distributed File System
because we needed a
large distributed file
system to store it on.
So we replaced that
on the GCP platform
with an Apache NiFi cluster that
we set up on the Google Compute
Engine, and it would
write its data to the GCS.
I'll cover these systems
in more detail soon.
For our big data
transformation jobs,
we replaced our
Hadoop map reduce jobs
with Apache Beam
on Google Dataflow.
For Hive, Impala, and
Teradata, they all
got replaced with BigQuery.
Our Informatica jobs
were writing to Teradata,
so to replace Teradata,
we wrote the results
to an on-prem Postgres database.
And then we used the
Apache NiFi cluster on GCE
to copy the data
daily to BigQuery.
For our big data
acquisition jobs, as I said,
we replaced it with an
Apache NiFi cluster on GCE.
And we installed those
as Docker containers
on Google's
container-optimized OS.
So the way it works is that the
vendor places their data files
on GCS every hour, and we have
a workflow running continuously
in Apache NiFi listing new
files that appear in the bucket,
fetching them,
doing pre-processing
on them, which is mainly
decompressing the data,
and writing it onto our own
GCS buckets for later processes
to work on.
And the NiFi workflows
also subscribe
to a Pub/Sub topic that accepts
commands for re-acquiring data.
In case there are
operational issues,
our operators can issue commands
through the NiFi cluster
to reacquire data.
So for our ETL that was running
as Hadoop map reduce jobs
as Python programs.
We wanted to reuse a lot of
the transformation functions
that we had on the
on-prem systems,
so we made a decision to migrate
to the Apache Beam Python SDK
and run it on the
Google Dataflow service.
So in order to do so, we
created agent machines
on Google Compute Engine that
has our automation engine
agent.
It's also running on Google
Container-Optimized OS,
so the agent is running as a
service in a Docker container
and accepts patch job commands
from our on-prem automation
engine server.
And those batch jobs launch a
container for each batch job
from application images
installed on the agent machine.
And each of those batch jobs
are data flow client jobs
that issue commands to the
Google Dataflow service
to run batch jobs
to process the data.
So it's taking the data
that NiFi had placed on GCS,
transforming it, and
putting the results in GCS.
So part of our Google
DoubleClick ad data
transformations is denormalizing
the data, looking up 20 fields
from nine tables.
We found it was hard
to write and maintain
in Python and
Dataflow, but it was
easy to write it as BigQuery
queries just having nine
left outer joins in the query.
And in our testing, we
found that it ran really
efficiently in BigQuery,
so that's what we're
using in production today.
And in the future, we are
preferring ELT and BigQuery
in most cases since it's
easier to write and maintain.
So another part
of the project is
that we needed to
get years of data
on the order of
hundreds of terabytes
from on-prem to
GCS and BigQuery.
So for data that's
only in Teradata,
we first copied
the data to Hadoop.
Once the data is on HDFS, we
can use Google's Cloud Storage
Connector, and we installed that
on our on-prem Hadoop cluster
to copy the data in
parallel up to GCS.
So we installed our GCS--
our Google service account
files on our client machines,
and then our on-prem
Hadoop cluster
could write the data to the GCS.
And it was extremely fast.
If we wanted to, we could
have copied all of our data
in just a few days.
Also, at that time,
BigQuery did not
support the parquet file format
for data loads to BigQuery.
So we created a
system that we could
write configuration files of
Hive queries for each table
that we needed to convert.
And those Hive queries
would convert the data types
and write Avro files on HDFS.
And we wrote
automation workflows
to do daily jobs to write
these Avro files on HDFS,
use the Hadoop DistCp command
to copy and parallel the GCS,
making use of Google's
Cloud Storage Connector,
and running the BQ load commands
to get it into BigQuery.
So for Informatica, we needed
to replace all the workflows
that target Teradata since
Teradata will be retired.
So we couldn't target
BigQuery directly
because all of those
jobs are written
as transactional
inserts and updates.
So what we decided to do is
we duplicated the workflows
and targeted them to an
on-prem Postgresql database.
It was on prem because of
limitations in the database
drivers we had that had
write latency issues.
So since Informatica
was on-prem,
the Postgresql database
also had to be on-prem.
So to get it into BigQuery,
we used our NiFi cluster
on Google Compute Engine.
We created workflows
that accepted commands
from Google Pub/Sub,
those commands
saying to copy tables from
the on-prem Postgresql
database to BigQuery.
And we added those
table copy jobs
to our daily schedules
and our automation engine.
We also created global flags
in our automation engine
for Teradata retirement,
and added preconditions
to our Teradata
workflows on those flags.
So just by changing one
flag, we can turn on and off
all of those Teradata workflows.
So now I'll cover some of
the technical challenges
we encountered during
the migration project.
So as I explained, we were
using this complicated system
of getting the
data into Postgres,
and then copying it once a
day using our NiFi cluster,
so we'd like to simplify
that in the future.
So we've written a
library of reusable code
for getting slowly changing
dimension data directly
into BigQuery.
The way the system works is
that new and updated records
are appended to log
tables in BigQuery.
The sources could either
be daily batch jobs that
append records from recent days
or could be real-time streaming
jobs that append to log tables.
And both sources are
subject to duplicates,
so we wrote this templatized
BigQuery SQL that
reads from the log tables and
creates new versions of slowly
changing dimension tables.
Two types of those
tables, Type 1
for writing the current
version of the record
to the destination table,
and Type 2, which is writing
deduplicated history
records for each key
to the destination table.
So the main parameters
for this library
is what's the source log
table that we're reading from,
what's the key for
this table, and what
are the fields that identify
the ordering or record
versions for that key.
And from that, we create
an order_by clause
with the most
recent record first.
So this is the basic template
for a Type 1 dimension table,
writing the current latest
version of the record
to the destination table.
You can see it's making use of
BigQuery's ARRAY_AGG functions,
ordering by that ORDER
BY clause we generated,
and picking the
most recent record.
And that replaces the
destination table.
For Type 2 dimension tables, we
write the deduplicated history,
and we add history fields
of effective start and end
timestamp of the record
in a third field, which
is a flag field indicating
whether this record is
the current record for this key.
So this is making use of
the windowing functions
that BigQuery supports.
You can see we're generating the
three extra fields I mentioned
and deduplicating the records.
Another problem we had to solve
is having atomic isolated data
sets for our Dataflow jobs.
So we needed the data
processed by Dataflow
to be atomic so that
downstream jobs see
just the complete
output or no output.
If a data flow job fails, we
don't want downstream jobs
to see partial data.
And it needs to be isolated.
If two concurrent jobs are
running at the same time,
we don't want them to be
using the same file names
and stepping on each other.
So GCS has ACID guarantees
for individual file objects,
but Dataflow runs in parallel
and produces a whole data
set of related files, and we
need these ACID guarantees
for the whole data set.
So we created GCS data set
standard and set of libraries
to support that standard.
And it uses two locations
on GCS, a data set
location and an index location.
The Dataflow job is
configured to use the data set
location, each job having a
unique ID in the destination.
And when the Dataflow job
completes successfully,
we write a metadata
JSON file to the index
location that has the
logical name of the data set.
And our libraries are written
so that downstream jobs can
get the latest version
of the metadata
and retrieves the data set
from the data set location.
Another decision
we had to make is
how to shard our fact tables.
So our big data fact tables
are all partitioned by day.
But we also have
distinct subsets
of data on a non-time field.
For instance, for our
Google DoubleClick Ad data,
we have the event type, such
as impression, click, or video
conversion.
So some queries are only
interested in a subset
of the event types, and we
want to reduce our query costs
by scanning only the event type
rows needed by those queries.
So the system we
came up with was
to load to multiple tables
that have the exact same field
schema, one table
for each event type.
And we created views that UNION
ALLs these tables together.
So queries can
just query the data
that they need by choosing
the views that they query.
Another decision we had to
make is about time zones.
So our decision was to use
BigQuery's timestamp type
in our physical tables.
So our transformations all
convert the timestamps to UTC
before loading
into those tables.
If users need to see data
in different time zones,
we create a view,
the view generating
extra DATETIME fields under
that specific time zone.
Another problem we
encountered during our project
was providing the BigQuery
table schema during loads.
We didn't have any
problems when loading
the fact tables, which is the
first things that we worked on.
We wrote to the fact tables.
They were partitioned
by day, as I explained,
so we're loading in
WRITE_TRUNCATE mode,
replacing those
daily partitions.
And we didn't need to supply
the table schema on those loads
because BigQuery preserves
the schema for these partition
tables.
But then we got to the
dimension part of the project,
as I explained earlier.
We were copying those
dimension tables once a day
from our NiFi workflows.
And the dimension tables
are not partitioned,
so we're loading to these
unpartitioned tables
also in WRITE_TRUNCATE mode
to overwrite the tables.
We found that the table
schema was not preserved then,
so we just had to
change our jobs
to provide the table
schemas for those jobs.
Next, Bhaskara will discuss
the Tableau migration
and our overall recommendations
from the experience we
had with our migration project.
BHASKARA PETA: Hello again.
I'll talk to you briefly about
our Tableau migration process
that we have implemented.
So the first thing we
did, we took an inventory
of all the workbooks,
tables, and reports
that we had to migrate.
And as you know, for any
company over a period of time,
you will create a lot of
reports which would be unused
once you take about six months
or one year, or many years.
So we took time to identify
those unused workbooks, tables,
and everything and we took them
out of the migration process
and that helped us with
the migration time as well.
We also took the priorities
from our stakeholders,
which is very important.
And also the conversion
was done based
on the priority given
by the stakeholders
so that they understand
when the tables are
coming for them to work with.
And the last thing is getting
the review and signoff
by the owners is also critical.
Next, let us look at the
conversion steps of the Tableau
workbooks itself.
And as you can see,
this is like a--
I hope you can see
the picture well.
This is like an assembly line.
You create a new data source
with a BigQuery connection,
and then rename the columns
same as existing data source.
Copy the calculated fields
to the new data source
and replace the old data source
with new BigQuery data source.
And then the last
type is validate.
So it's like an assembly line.
You repeat this for
each and every workbook.
Now let us see some
of the challenges
that we faced during
the migration.
So for Tableau
conversion, what we did--
we have migrated some
stale data to cloud to help
with the initial conversion.
We did this mainly because we
would like both the migration
and also Tableau conversion
to go in parallel so that we
are not waiting on one another.
At the same time,
make the progress
with the project with the
given timeline that we have.
But because of that, we had to
validate some of the reports
twice, but I think that's OK.
We couldn't avoid it.
And then as we are
doing the migration,
business is not going to stop
because they'll continuously
create the reports.
And it was a challenge
for us to keep up
with all the new workbooks that
are being created, and then
bringing them into the
conversion pipeline,
and then plan the conversion.
And that added some timeline
for us, but it was a challenge
and we were able
to mitigate that.
And then if you look at
converting all these workbooks,
it took some time for us
to get the hang of it.
What is the best way to
migrate in a quick way?
So it is like extract, convert
to Tableau, owner review,
and then rinse,
repeat, sign off.
It is a assembly line,
as we talked before.
So I'm sure some of
the users-- some of you
might be looking at
Tableau migration.
So I would like to
talk to you about some
of the tips about
the Tableau migration
that might be useful for you
based on what we thought.
So if you are using custom
SQLs in Tableau conversions,
make sure to include the
workbook name as a comment
of the first line of the SQL.
And this will help you a lot in
identifying any SQLs that you
would like to tune further and
identify what is the workbook
name and everything.
And one way to identify is
going through the audit logs.
If you go through
the audit logs,
you can only look at the
SQLs that are running,
but not the workbook names.
So that is a way you can
get the workbook name.
Pardon me, David,
for saying this.
I hope you're OK
with me saying this.
A big no-no for
using select star
on any of your largest tables.
You will get annoyed
pretty quickly
once you start using
BigQuery, and that is so--
especially if you are coming
from a traditional relational
database because that
is how we got to know.
Because the costs are going to
be pretty high if you are using
select star on large
tables because the cost
is based on the amount
of data that you
are scanning in the query.
There are some
standards that you
have to follow for
Tableau conversions.
For example, for
column aliases, you
have to use only letters,
numbers, and underscore.
Then it should start with a
letter or underscore only,
and the date format
that BigQuery accepts
is in a specific
format, YYYY-MM-DD.
Now I would like
to show you some
of the experiences from the
stakeholders, what they said
about BigQuery, now that
all the migration is
completed, in their own words.
These are all self-explanatory.
As you can see,
they thought that it
is kind of a
self-service platform
because they were
able to automate
the queries by themselves.
They were able to create
the summary tables
without asking for any help.
Also, they were able to share
the queries across the project
repo, which is a great
feature that they loved it.
And then BigQuery.
All the heavy lifting
was done using BigQuery,
whereas they were only
looking at smaller data
sets when they were working
with Python Notebooks.
That is also another
great feature.
And also, it is a significantly
faster processing,
according to what the
stakeholders have said.
And they were able to
work with truly big data
because in the past, when they
were running atomic queries,
sometimes it is taking forever
in some of the databases.
But now, they're all getting the
data in a very, very reasonable
time.
In some cases, within a
few seconds and minutes,
which is great.
And also, another thing we did,
we empowered the stakeholders
in some cases.
We give the ownership
of the projects
to some of the key stakeholders.
That helped them to be
self-sufficient in what
they would like to do.
And they're pretty
happy with it.
And also, their team was
able to do a lot of things
without getting any help
from other central teams.
Also, as we discussed before,
we migrated the atomic data
wherein we introduced
the array fields.
And then these array
functions actually
helped us with improving the
performance on the queries,
and also reducing the
cost on the queries
that we are running
on the atomic data.
And also, it has simplified
the code from a few pages
to a few lines of code.
This is a great feature.
And if you are having
any large data sets
and if you can introduce these
functionalities, please do so.
And also, another
interesting feature
that the customers have
liked was the integration
of Google Sheets with BigQuery.
And this one was
definitely liked
by some of the stakeholders
in our company.
Now let us look at some
of the big wins for us.
What are the big wins
that we have seen?
As you have seen in the previous
slides, happy stakeholders.
What else we need?
That's what we are
all striving for.
We want to make the
customers happy,
and that is what happened
with the BigQuery migration.
Significant
improvement with SLAs,
and we have seen a
lot of improvement.
And also, for Super Bowl LIII
just a couple of months ago,
we were able to process
the largest data
sets during that event
without any problem,
without any limitations on the
database sizes, which is great.
Our operations team,
they were able to reduce
the footprint of the
data center because we
were able to shut down
Teradata and Hadoop.
And then, our engineers
are able to focus
on the real problems rather than
some of the day-to-day issues
that we have been seeing with
our on-premise infrastructure.
Also, we were able to
reduce the number of tables
from on-premise to cloud.
We were able to
reduce, I think--
at least about 50% of the tables
we were able to eliminate.
Because as I said before,
over a period of time,
you create the tables
and we never use them
because the functionality have
changed or the project got
dumped out and
nobody is using it.
And we never know
that, so we took time
to identify those
tables and then
remove them from the migration.
Reduced dependency is
increased productivity,
and that is what we have
seen with the cloud migration
because everybody was able to do
a lot of the tasks on their own
with less dependency
on the central teams.
Now that we are
coming to the end,
I would like you to leave
with some of the takeaways
that we learned
from this migration.
Probably they would
be useful for you
if you are planning on
migrating data to the cloud.
Training, training, training.
Don't get us wrong.
We did train our engineers.
But at the end, when we did the
retrospective of the project,
we thought that we could
do much more training
for our engineers.
And also, if you are
working in a small team,
make sure to cross-train
your engineers
across different products,
and that will help a lot.
Also, if you can, train
on your own company data
rather than using
superstore data.
Because the analysts will get
early on hands-on experience
with your own data.
And since you're migrating
to a new platform,
new software, new
processes, make
sure you have that feedback loop
to identify the improvements
that you need to make
on the new processes
that you are implementing.
Because sometimes,
we ignore that,
but I think what we
have seen is it's always
good to have that feedback.
And the task force.
This is something that
worked very, very well for us
because they're
invested in the process.
They have been working with us
and we are working with them
all through the migration
to make any major decisions
around cloud migration.
And they're happy
to be part of it.
And it helps them to know
how things are changing
and how they should be prepared.
And also, it helps them to
get early access to the data
and also help identifying
the issues early on.
And then, take time
to discover and retire
any obsolete
processes or tables.
Even though sometimes,
it is time-consuming
because it took some time for
us to go through all the logs
and everything.
But it will help you
in the migration time
and the overall
process so that you
can remove the clutter
in the new platform.
The next one is try to migrate
most recent data to the cloud
first.
In our case, that
is what we did.
And it helped the analysts to
give early access to the data.
And also, they were able to play
with our own data in the cloud
and help us to give us the
feedback on identifying
the problems early on.
That is a great
thing that helped us.
And when we did that, we
also copied the dimension
data to the cloud so that
they can get the entire data
set to play with.
Query costs.
This is very, very important.
And even now, we have been
seeing some of the areas
where we can improve
in our company.
But what we did, especially
with our cloud migration,
we have created
some alerts early on
to alert us if anybody
is running a query--
if the cost is exceeding
a certain limit,
we'll get an email or alert.
So it's like training the
users to tell them, hey, this
is the query you ran and
this query cost you $1,000.
So please be mindful
because we had queries--
initially, when we started
working with BigQuery,
there were users who would
run the queries worth $8,000.
You may not believe
it, but that is true.
But pretty quickly, we
were able to contain that,
and then everybody now is
able to run the queries very
effectively, and those
alerts helped us.
And we are continuously
improving on how well
we can improve that process.
Also, our strategy with
go live is sequential.
And that helped us a lot
because it gave us momentum.
Once we go live with
first business unit,
it gave us the momentum
for the rest of the groups
to go live because
they have seen
other people, other
business units, going live.
And that helped
us and also them.
So that's what I would suggest.
If you have many,
many brands, I think
you can take that approach.
And as you have seen, this is
a very, very complex project
over many, many brands with a
lot of different priorities.
And we have a great team
and excellent stakeholders,
and that is how we
were able to do it.
That's all we
have, and thank you
for joining our session today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]